[Music]
foreign
I've been really open with my group
about and they know me to a T and like
if it ain't right they're the first be
like hey man you good like what's what's
going on and we you know you got to
build your group you you have an amazing
group like the people that uh look up to
you and follow like I think like a
really great reflection is like people
who like you like people who like you
dope hard-working cool amazing bright uh
talented uh interesting people like all
of them and that's like that just speaks
so truly that's how I knew you were dope
would do that yeah that dude I tell you
a really funny thing that's funny I
thought you were talking about yourself
I thought I didn't know you've talked
about me
thanks man
so this is like this is how I knew you
were my favorite actor so my boys were
watching uh
we're watching your a show of yours and
you were uh
so I get me and my boys and I always get
this feeling when I see a sex scene in a
movie or a TV or whatever maybe it's
because I just grew up Catholic and yeah
you're gonna go to Hell whatever but I
always get that feeling I'm watching it
with my mom yeah like even if I'm with
my boys like I'm like I don't want to
like watch like you know I don't want to
see Jude large stroke like you know what
I mean like I'm like I I don't know but
with you I'm like yeah yeah dude yeah
get in there dude like we're rooting for
you we're like yeah get get get it man
like that's how I knew you were my
favorite that
ugly [__] [__] like we can
all [__] you know for all of us that
there's an animal and he deserves that
right now and he works really hard and
I'm so appreciative that he's getting
some ass look at his ears yeah no but
like yeah like that's that you're the
only person and my boy was like yeah I
do want to see you succeed in the
bedroom like it's like that like it's so
fun it's so [__] funny perfect show
for me to watch
that is so funny dude but yeah that I
don't know how I got there you know you
are known so much for you and and you
you you're you're extraordinarily like
well known and [__] and I get that and I
I get I get the pressure on that I just
I I hope that uh
I hope that that's easy you know I hope
that and if it's not easy I hope it gets
easier oh thanks man it is getting it's
getting easier because I get I'm
starting to get I guess the game a
little bit yeah
yo who is uh like who who are like the
these guys to you like who like some of
the people that are here today so Simon
is my brother from another brother uh
we're just the same person uh I met
Simon 10 years ago on the the Happy
Madison lot uh Sandler when he had a
Sony deal he had a house on yeah I
remember talking about dude who does it
right that dude had a [__] house on
the Sony live with his boys in there and
I remember I had like a general meeting
with like Alan Covert or one of his uh
you know producers and I was just like
in my head I was like I wonder if I'm
gonna get to see the Sandman oh my God
it's so crazy and I'm sitting there just
like just a picture like because I
looked this pretty much say for like 19
just like [__] just like geeky like
my shoulders are up to here just like so
nerdy just like this this is my idol I
auditioned for Big Daddy when I was like
[__] four years old and so excited
didn't know he was there he just comes
out giant T-shirt with like a little bit
of Pizza on it and like Bass basketball
shorts and high socks and he's just like
goes into the fridge gets a gator and he
just goes hey did my wife send you here
to make me seem fat
and I just went huh what he goes you're
gonna be all right kid I just walked out
and I was just like
what the [__] so I just like went up to
the top the black top of that parking
lot was just sitting there chilling and
he had a he's a basketball nut so he has
Hoops everywhere Simon's up there
and swartson and we just played ball and
we like kind of connected and then like
weirdly like couple years later we we
became friendly and now you know pretty
much roommates and Alex I met uh I used
to have social media and I wasn't really
good at social media I would post like
just pictures of Tony Soprano in like
the pool and be like Monday like I was
like such a little thought like a little
like thotty girl on Instagram and I was
just obsessed with The Sopranos and I
did this show in DC at the Arlington
Draft House
um and it was at the time I used to do
meet and greets because you know there's
only like 100 people whatever and Alex
came and I think he was like 18 or 19 in
college and uh
he just came up and he HBO back in the
day before it was like streaming or
whatever to get people excited they
would send like care packages in the
mail and they sent like like Supreme new
season of Sopranos was going to come out
so they sent a Sopranos Globe it's
actually a super rare globe and it's
hard to find and
I met him after and he didn't ask for a
picture or anything he just was like he
gave me this globe and he was just like
hey I stole this from my dad I figured
you would really like it I was like well
we just became best friends and like now
he could ruin my life with the Press of
a button and I trust him with everything
and he's uh yeah he's he's my best
friend we just uh yeah just it's a great
we got a great group now yeah and John I
met uh we're working on uh
this uh Ramon's script with uh Netflix
and we were introduced and just
immediately were just like oh yeah you
get it you know and and we we work
together on uh on my show and it just
you know organic cool people meeting
cool people that have very similar
interests and uh and but more
importantly like I respect them all as
amazing human beings that I look forward
to hang with them so it's always a treat
when you hang out with these guys [__]
yeah
[Music]
all right
hey what's going on everybody it's John
Bam Bam the dog uh first on behalf of
both of us and everybody from the real
ones team I just want to sincerely thank
you guys for for tuning in the folks
that I bring on the show they're family
to me and uh being able to tell their
stories and bringing you into their
world is something I'm I'm just super
proud of and uh again grateful that you
guys tune in we've decided we want to
take things just a step further it's a
patreon community and basically what
that means is if you become a part of
this community look I already board Bam
Bam if you want to become a part of this
community you're going to be able to
hear episodes early and all that ad free
and all that good stuff but there's all
this behind the scenes footage all this
stuff that we've shot that really brings
you into the folks that we've had on the
show really brings you into their world
live chats with me and the folks that I
bring on the show to talk about their
world talk about the issues that they're
dealing with but their triumphs and
their tragedies just go to patreon slash
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole idea
idea was something about building
bridges and and bringing people together
and bringing folks that often don't get
the mic and given the mic to them so the
fact that you guys tuned in means the
world anyways again thank you be good to
each other out there rock and roll
I'm gonna get a workout in a little bit
with my man Eric Linden stud coordinator
from The Punisher he's coming all the
way up because we're about to get after
it and when that's done he asked me in
the car are you gonna have my shake
ready and I know what that means am I
gonna have my son Warrior Shake they've
got the active protein but they also
have this collagen protein which is
amazing they also have the warrior blend
which is a little bit lighter if you're
trying to cut and uh I believe in it I
believe in that some Warrior stuff go to
www.sunwarrior.com
real ones
[Music]